[MUSIC]
It is September 13, 1833,
in the Northeastern Indian
port city of Kolkata.
It is 90 degrees outside and
the air is humid.
You're in a crowd anxiously waiting,
unsure if you're about to
see a historical feat of human
ingenuity or an elaborate prank.
Then slowly and steadily off the horizon,
a brig named Tuscany approaches.
In it, 100 tons of ice, cut in blocks and
stacked neatly against one another,
having just finished a four month voyage,
all the way from Boston.
What you just witnessed was the journey
along one of the first international
temperature-controlled supply chain,
also known as the cold chain.
The man behind this cold
chain was Frederic Tudor,
deservedly nicknamed The Ice King.
Tudor started this icy empire by
harvesting natural ice in the dead of
New England winter, then delivering
it first across the United States and
eventually to Great Britain and India.
Whilst this journey was long and
its historical significance monumental,
Tudor's cold chain from a logistical
perspective was extraordinarily simple.
For a long time, the only commodity
he transported was ice and
ice kept itself cool as long as
there was sufficient insulation.
So Tudor invested heavily in these
ice houses along the ports and
his business took off.
Now in the two centuries that followed,
the cold chain had come a long way.
Today, the cold chain is more complex and
more global than ever before.
Just to give you a sense of its scale and
complexity, nowadays for a piece of
imported fruit to get to you and me,
it will roughly go through 20 steps.
Here's a chart just to
show you what that's like.
In the last three years working as a food
investor, I have seen this process
in play day in and day out, in lettuce
fields, in sew plants, and in refrigerated
trucks delivering imported cheese to
pizzerias all across New York City.
I marveled at this well oiled
machine that connects growers,
manufacturers, distributors,
retailers, and consumers.
The cold chain enables us to introduce
diversity and abundance into our diet.
It removes seasonality and
distances from food.
It gives us choices so
that food is not just about survival, but
part of our identity.
That is, until this all stopped working.
Many of these images may
look familiar to you.
Bagel shops without cream cheese.
Starbucks without Frappuccino.
KFC without chicken tenders.
For me, a broken cold chain meant
spending hours on the phone with
our logistics providers,
telling them how unacceptable it was for
them to leave frozen ready meals in
a hot truck for 24 hours too long.
Our cold chain is susceptible
to disruptions, and
we've had an awful lot of
disruptions in the last two years.
Not only that,
the cold chain is also fossil fueled and
incredibly energy-intensive.
According to the UN,
the food cold chain accounts for
about 1.2 gigatons of co2 emissions.
That is about 1% of total
global annual emissions.
So in between worrying about
the revenue loss from customers
receiving spoiled food, and
the costs associated with that
extra pack of dry ice I now need to
budget for it in the deliveries.
I couldn't help but wonder,
how can we make this better?
One solution came to mind, and
it's almost too obvious and too logical.
Why not simplify the supply chain?
Do what the industry calls nearshoring.
Take out a few nodes here and there,
shorten the distance traveled,
source locally, eat farm to fork.
It's simple, sustainable,
and more resilient, right?
Not so fast.
To illustrate just how complicated
the cold chain is and how hard it is to
disentangle even a tiny portion of it, let
me take you on a journey of one commodity.
Walk into any Western European
supermarket and
you will see these beautiful
uniform fresh French green beans.
These beans were in the fields just 48
hours ago in the rural villages outside
Bobo-Dioulasso in Burkina Faso, among many
other former European colonies in Africa.
These beans were handpicked by local
manual labor when it's hot and
sunny outside, and
then immediately chilled to about 40
degrees Fahrenheit to
ensure high export quality.
They're then loaded onto
refrigerated trucks to be packed at
a temperature-controlled facility.
Then, lastly, loaded onto a jet
flying directly to Paris.
Now what is missing from this picture
of seamless modern miracle is the fact
that many of these villages don't
have paved roads or electricity.
These farmers rely on charcoal to chill
the beans instead of refrigerators,
before sending the beans to an air
conditioned facility to be processed.
Many of these farmers also have come
to rely on this high value export crop
as their sole source of income.
And they import shelf stable food for
their own consumption.
Now if we decide that we
want to in source the beans,
these farmers would lose their livelihood
and the local economy would collapse.
But perhaps most ironically,
those who grow the beans cannot
even afford to eat them.
The lack of cold storage meant
that most of these beans would rot
before the locals could get
a chance to consume them.
You see,
eating locally requires refrigeration,
and refrigeration is simply too expensive.
In fact, scientists estimate
that as much as 40% of the fresh
food produced in Africa is lost due
to inadequate cold chains annually.
Globally, the carbon
footprint of food loss and
food waste is four times the carbon
footprint of the cold chain itself.
So counter intuitively for
us to solve for a less carbon-intensive
food ecosystem means adding cold
chain capacity and adding it quickly.
And since I'm talking to about 200 of
you who will be future business leaders,
I want to talk about what you can do.
As your companies rethink about your
supply chain in the post-pandemic world,
it is imperative that you go beyond
the cookie cutter diversification or
nearshoring strategies that your
consultants keep pitching you about and
think about the whole ecosystem.
Resiliency comes from strengthening
the entire supply chain,
and it begins with investing
in the most fragile links,
like bringing roads,
bringing electricity, and
bringing refrigeration to those
villages in Burkina Faso.
Tudor understood that until
every port had an ice house,
there was no cross Atlantic ice trade.
Similarly, there is no resilient
global supply chain if farmers
don't have the infrastructure
to store what they've produced.
This is also good for business.
Better cold storage at the point
of harvest meant fresher,
higher quality produce for your company.
It decreases food loss and also makes for
more predictable supplies.
This will save you money and
is also more sustainable.
And finally, there's massive social
benefits for the local community.
They'll obviously get access to better,
safer, and more nutritious food.
But more importantly, the same set
of cold storage infrastructure
will also provide access
to lifesaving drugs and
vaccines like what we've
seen in the last two years.
The pandemic gave us
an opportunity to rethink and
reimagine what the future
cold chain should look like.
Let's take a page from
the Ice King's playbook and
start investing in the weakest
link in this global system.
Only then will we be able to
provide freshness to all,
resiliently, sustainably, and equitably.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]